I understand what you mean,
but this one does not.
It fits perfect and it's been washed and dried several times.
I'm 5 9, I'm pretty tall.
I have a decently long torso,
I have decently long legs,
and it comes on. It's like
it doesn't cover my whole booty,
but it comes right up, like the chubbiest part of my booty.
So I kinda like that too. It makes it look juicy.
It's not sure. I'm.
I'm telling you, I was highly surprised at how much I like this thing.
I was highly surprised at how comfortable and awesome it is.
Like, I.
I was skeptical and then I was amazed at how much I liked it.
So I fucking highly recommended.
I'm 5 9, I'm super tall.
Most shit fits me funny. I highly recommend it.